Hello,
now,
do I think that there will be newspaper
men and women's?
Yes,
too.
I think that the New York Times will
survive the Internet.
Absolutely.
Their traffic is unbelievable striking.
Um,
do I think most cities in Israel as
well?
I'm just not sure.
They're only hope and their aim.
So says the big man at the top of the
boards is to go local.
So even the Los Angeles Times is being
pressured to become a local newspaper in
a larger sense of what local is in La.
So there are very few truly national
papers left and foreign bureaus are by
the gear are being cut down.
Um,
the biggest problem is I understood as I
see that the newspapers face is that
websites like google glean off the
content from a newspaper without the
revenue from that content going to the
newspaper.
In other words,
google hat makes revenue from these ads,
but they get the content for vr
virtually for free.
Um,
you have a whole generation,
my generation and younger who is
starting to expect print news for free.
They were up in arms because they were
being asked to pay $50 a year for the
New York Times Tacan,
which I find,
again,
absurd that they would be so aghast over
that.
Um,
you know,
I think newspapers are in trouble.
It's a terrible time to be a reporter.
There's no doubt about that.
There's less jobs,
there's less demand in,
uh,
in the American public for international
news and there's less demand clearly to
our less desire among people to pay for
their news.
So now I don't think it's a good time.